hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast pcr testing in rodent health
monitoring program where are we exactly
I am Judy O'Rourke of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event we
are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by the andersons lab
bedding products as the sole
manufacturer of better cogs the
andersons has provided the research
community with the most trusted name in
bedding since nineteen sixty two from
irradiated and qualified products
available in autoclavable and bulk bags
to sterility and heavy metal testing the
andersons providing number of services
to the industry for information please
visit www Anderson's lab bedding com we
have a few important announcements
before we begin this webcast it's
designed to be interactive and we
encourage you to ask questions during
the event you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can you can
enlarge the slide window by clicking on
the screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you have
any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem for the green Q&A button
lower left I would now like to introduce
today's speaker dr. Matthias Leblanc dr.
LeBlanc is the assistant director of the
animal resources department at the salk
institute for biological studies he
obtained his doctorate in veterinary
medicine from university of montreal in
1997 soon after he pursued a masters and
a PhD degree in physiology and
endocrinology dr. LeBlanc did a
residency in veterinary pathology at the
University of Montreal while remaining
active in lab animals science he moved
on to the position of assistant director
and veterinary pathologist at the Salk
Institute in 2007 where he is
responsible for the veterinary care
diagnostic and preventative medicine
as well as the comparative pathology
program dr. LeBlanc is also a staff
scientist in the gene expression
laboratory and has published on cancer
research and metabolism and several high
impact journals such as cell cancer cell
and nature medicine I will now turn it
over to dr. LeBlanc for his presentation
thank you Judy and good morning
everybody I hope everybody can hear me
well so as Judy said I'm going to talk
about environmental PCR testing and
Roland health monitoring where are we
exactly so we just want to say a few
things first I try to put a I just came
back from Europe vacation vacations in
Europe in Paris Spain and Portugal so I
I've added some pictures of my trip in
the presentation so if you get bored
well at least I hope you're going to
have a good good good time looking at
the pictures so I'd like to talk about
environmental pcr and testing I'd like
to start with a simple very simple
definition what is doubt that isn't now
and based on the Webster dictionary it
means a feeling of uncertainty or lack
of conviction and why did I start with
that definition it's just to say that
health monitoring in general is not an
exact science it's very complicated just
as the also diagnostic assays so we
think that you know everything is
foolproof in this area and that we
should not doubt what we have when when
a lab or a given lab gives us results we
should think well you know what that's
that if the labs found a positive its
positive and that's good well that's not
true as in science you should always
doubt and remain critical State remain
critical and ask questions that's the
best way to go and I hope that this
presentation will will prove that point
like Leonardo da Vinci said
fresh he said he no good back here which
means who do not doubt acquires little
you need to doubt when it comes to a
health monitoring and diagnostic assays
always down a little and don't be afraid
to ask questions so soil bedding sandals
are definitely not always efficient and
reliable that will revealing the
presence of pathogens and Master own
colonies especially when their housing
individually ventilated cages and when
the pathogen province is low which is
the case for most of your facilities
with the advent of new molecular
techniques several several investigators
and severals venerians have proposed
alternatives to soil bedding sandals
such as pcr analysis of environmental
samples from either the cage or from
exhaust from rack exhaust Planum to
improve the defection of pathogens and
that's great and I believe that we're
growing in that direction so taking
advantage of the sensitivity of PCR
assays different investigators have
suggested to sample areas where agent
Latin particles accumulate in out
concentrations such as exhaust filters
or plenum of vanilla ventilator racks to
detect pathogens at the right level
there was some original success
especially with ERISA lies viruses like
stand I or mhd and definitely with fur
mites there was a good publication on
that but then some of god and very
excited and things got a little bit of a
out of hand I got this quote from a
publication that was given to me by my
colleague John ruder was the senior
director of the animal resource
department gave me that publication of
what a few months ago and when I read it
I was kind of flabbergasted I was like
what what is this and and the
publication said using swath of lemon
plenum or Iraq HEPA filters to monitor
iraq for infectious agent completely
eliminates the needs for bedding sandals
for exhaust air dust compatible racks we
can detect virtual virtually all agents
by air sampling many more than with soil
banging semi well I do understand that
soul bedding sentinels is not perfect
but
I went back to my colleague John has
said where could he take that did I miss
something that I I didn't read all the
publications with all the literature and
he said well I don't know I was as
surprised as you the fact is that there
are very few systematic studies on the
efficiency of exhaust plenum to detect
the presence of pathogens in naturally
infected and I do say naturally infected
colonies or studies that have determined
the optimal environmental sampling
strategies for those exhaust plan and
pcr for different microorganisms so when
you read the things in publications
always take critical and say well is
that true is that absolutely true when I
read this I said no that's not possible
and I went back and I hope that this
case study that this case study that we
are that we had here at the Salk
Institute world will try to illustrate
that well and an illustrate that health
monitoring in general is not
straightforward and then whenever using
new technologies or new testing
paradigms you need to remain critical
ask questions and remains remember some
basic concepts especially before taking
costly action that may disruptive to
your clients namely your research
community always interpret results very
cautiously with an overall understanding
of this testing methodology the
intrinsic controls and all the variables
that may affect the results just as in
any diagnostic test pcrs are not
bulletproof and don't take for cash
everything you read in publications so
let's talk about the Salk Institute I'm
going to talk about our program just
very quickly so to give you a broch an
overall context the salk institute for
biological studies is in La Jolla and
the San Diego region we're a nonprofit
research institution that was funded by
Jonas Salk in 1960 the inventor of the
polio vaccine we consistently ranked
amongst the leading research institution
in the world in fact our Institute on
strain about point
700 scientists including five Nobel
prizes normal prize winners and and our
labs are currently home to nine hhmi
investigators and 14 members of the
national academy of science our major
areas of research is molecular biology
genetics neuroscience plant biology we
have a typical medium-sized animal care
news program the stock animal resource
department supports teaching and
research about of about 47 faculty or
labs and their students we are of course
a like accredited and we operate about
45,000 square feet of Miriam including
two miles barrier facilities namely
staff and TG the names are important
later to understand the presentation
akan convent conventional multi-species
facility craft and five other satellite
facilities most of our roles are housed
in the barrier facility staff with an
average daily census of about 14,000
cages mostly in micro Isolators on
ventilated rocks ah bio security program
is fairly standard uh I just want to
remind what is a bio security program
it's all the measures taken to prevent
containing eradicate pathogens so our
bio security program is standardized in
all in all our facilities and is
regularly optimized according to
contemporary standards to minimize
pathogen outbreaks of course being an
academic institution there's a lot of
challenges a lot of investigators lots
of those dogs that not do not
necessarily follow procedures so we do
have reaches in our bio security program
that leads to output but nonetheless we
have a very stringent security program
for example we have restricted access to
our facilities with a stringent training
program all our investigators postdocs
must go through annual retraining when
they work in our facilities to make sure
that they follow procedures and are up
to date we have a highly regulated
traffic flow for both the staff and the
animals with a one way out traffic flow
for mice in our barrier facility once
they leave the facility they never come
back all transfers of animals
train facilities and rooms must be
approved handled and documented by the
animal resource department and that's
very important for us because whenever
there's an outbreak with the movement of
animals we need to be able to look at
where the animals from positive rooms of
God so that we can trace that and risk
assess the outbreak in other rooms we
have strict strict PPE all our imports
from non improve vendors in the barrier
Muslim embryo read arrive and tested
prior to release all our biological are
tested for mural pathogens prior to use
that's only a few components of our
Secretary of security program but as I
said in an academic institution as you
as most of you know it's very hard to
maintain this program and breaches do
occur and we do get pathogen job but it
can that's why we do have a health
surveillance monitoring program the
hell's our health surveillance program
is meant to give us a broad overview of
the health status of our own colonies
but always remember that these programs
especially those based on soil bedding
sentinels are they're not efficient at
detecting all pathogens in ruins and
also results are not our retrospective
so whenever you have results from a
health surveillance program remember
what you have at that time in point when
you tested the animals might have been
there for weeks to months so take your
time to analyze the results understand
and confirm the result and take your
time before taking any harsh decisions
it's not because you have a positive
that you need to act immediately so our
health sonics our health monitoring
program is based on sold adding
sentinels having trouble with my
computer I'm sorry so we have it's
fairly standard once an old cage / half
rack that contained two nite swindling
Swiss Webster females that are replaced
and tested serologically every quarter
for pathogens and then once a year all
our sandals are also shipped to
reference lab for comprehensive necropsy
bacteriology fecal pcr
in the parasites and pail pcr for
ectoparasites them any positive results
any positive results must be confirmed
on the Sentinel on the Sentinel cohort
by a secondary method and as well as I'm
calling me nice before we do anything so
a bit more about our mouths barrier
facility the vast majority of our myosin
house in our barrier facility are micro
Isolators on allentown HEPA filter racks
and they must be autumn eyes must be
manipulated in 80s animal transportation
station or BSL two cabinets using strict
the septic technique with liberal use of
verkan s disinfectant a few of our mice
are housed on static micro Isolators and
handle an open air in our behavioral
testing suite our mice are fed
irradiated Rowan chow RoR are given our
water and cages are have corn cob
bedding and critical mass for enrichment
the rated-r own died i just want to
mention one thing we at NPV here at the
stock for about 15 years and we were
convinced based on on the epidemiology
of our outrage that it came from the
feed and we switched from aradia diet
about five years ago when we completely
eliminated MPD from a farm are far from
from our from our facilities another
point is that in our bat mouth barrier
facility in edison important point racks
are disassembled fully decon an
autoclave annually arcadja artistic
seven to ten days k changing cycle most
k jism the vast majority of our cages in
our none of other clave rooms in our
better facility are sanitizing our
tunnel washer with standard 185 I water
what about five percent of the cages are
autoclaved with the bedding MV crinkle
nest for prior to use for our
immunodeficient and sensitive strains so
start the case report we have to come
back to jun 2013 that was our big
sentinel
quarter when where we send all our
sandals out to our reference lab for
company cropsey etc and we were waiting
for the results of of the of the
Sentinels everything had been sent and
remember very well it was raining that
day and I was coming to work that's very
rare in California and in san diego i
think it's ring what five or six times
since i've started in almost seven years
or eight years I've been here and so I
sit down on Mayim on my email in the
morning and I get a dreaded I get a
dreaded email saying other you have
positive on you have positive results so
I go see and I see that two sentinels in
two different rooms in our barrier
facility staff was positive for a
specular statue Tara on fecal pcr good
alright that's not a good news pinworm
is not certainly not something wrong in
your facility and we had had we had firm
I'd outbreak in the past but we didn't
have pinworm outbreak so we're kind of
not very happy with it but we said you
know we need to confirm that it's an
unexpected positive result let's take
the time to confirm that so we did
secondary confirmation we did fecal
flows and direct sequel exam on the
sentinel we asked the reference lab to
do that and then we add the cage cohorts
of those sentinels here still at the
Institute so we did that and we also
test it calling animals and you know
what they were positive we saw some some
some worms in the sea camp we truly
really were confident that those two
room were positive all the other rooms
in our barrier facility and all our
facilities were negative based on
difficult pcr so at that point we say
zilla contained a out breaking or
isolated outbreak in two rooms or is
there something more so the first day at
first step was to quarantine the room
implements tricked out traffic flow and
confirm the results and that's what we
did again always consider that central
results are retrospective so it's been
several weeks to seven
months since it's been there always take
time to confirm and think about the most
appropriate to plan before taking harsh
harsh decision that may be costly and
get especially get on the nerve of your
scientific community once we've
confirmed once you've confirmed results
well you need to determine the extent
you know you always need to chase you
don't want to chase your tail especially
with without brakes you might have
pathogens in two rooms by sentinels but
it doesn't mean that you know the
pathogen that is not is not present in
other rooms especially in an academic
institution where you have so much
collaborative work it's very probable
that your sentinels have not you know
picked up a pathogen in another room so
you need to determine the extent once
you've determined the extent you know
what's what you have in your facility
then you need to communicate to your
investigator then treat and test the
efficiency of your of your treatments
and I want to touch base quickly on
communication here communication for us
is absolutely essential when you have
any outbreak it since that it's
essential for the success of our
pathogen content containment and
eradication planning to me and if you
don't communicate effectively with your
scientific community you're going to
have problems you need to reach out to
them you need to organize meeting
explaining to explain to them and make
them feel that they have a vested
interest in resolving the situation and
that they will play an active role in
resolving the situation we do open
conferences really do meetings with lab
managers we do emails and read and
written communication whatever in
general I can I can tell you that in
communication written communications are
very poor at conveying your message we
always get you know people don't read
their emails people don't read letters
however we find that lab managers are
the best people to work with the lab
managers in general are the bridge
between the P I was too busy to take
care of problems at the facility level
and the postdocs are too busy
their research if we can keep the lab
managers involved and make them feel
that they have an important role in our
in our program that's an amazing step in
reaching a successful resolution and
managing successful successfully any
pathogen outbreak so considering the
biology of the parasites of the pinworms
its persistence and resistant
environment and the collaborative nature
of research and academic institution we
were very concerned that the two
isolated cases was just the tip of the
iceberg and be out there and that the
outbreak also involved are the rooms as
such we said well we need to implement a
very large testing program in all
facilities to determine the extent of
the infection before deciding on a
definitive containment and eradication
plan so how did we do that first all the
remaining sentinel chords that we still
had were tested by fecal floats pure
perianal take us because sometimes you
have Julie infection with a stick your
diary sense of fashion and direct sequel
exams all we're negative good so
basically our fecal PCR were negative in
all the other rooms and now people flows
very now anal taste that's a tape test
and sequel exams are negative you gave
us some confidence that it was isolated
but that's not enough we also tested all
the transferred animals from the
positive rooms to other rooms in the
past year as well as their offerings or
relative relative still present by fecal
floats perianal tape test and when
possible when they latter report were
willing to give us animals by direct
sequel exam this was possible because we
track all transfer between rooms and
facilities and I think that's very
important in any man any pathogen
outbreak management all those were
negative again so it seems that there
were no animals that it's looked like
that at least two are the best of our
knowledge there are no animals that were
transferred to other rooms were or
positive then we did environmental PCR
testing on room surfaces and facility
HVAC in both the two positive rooms
can burn positive positive rooms as well
as the behavioral and procedural testing
suite where the myself positive rooms
could have been used in open air that's
because in its it's well known and
convened in enrolling County is infected
with pinworm that are conventionally
house and where when you do open air you
can contaminate your HVAC you can
contaminate surfaces so we thought you
know environmental PCR testing of swim
surfaces and HVAC might be a good way to
see if we have contamination
environmental contamination all we're
negative wow surprising seems that
everything is in those two rooms and
it's well contained at that point where
we're not trying where we're not very
we're not satisfied that's where the
word problems start um we said there was
a lot of talks based on several
publications that you know we could test
at the RAC levels we could test plenums
of rock and determinants and determine
if an agent is there at the RAC level by
testing ventilator rocks and most
positive pressure ventilator acts
including our entire rack software in a
similar fashion basically a HEPA
filtered air that is circulated in the
cages at 60 to 70 air changes per hour
which creates a barrier at the cage
level and also eliminates although or
reduces the waste products from the cage
then air from each shelf is collected
and channeled through an aura zontal
exhaust manifold and then to a common
vertical exhaust plenum before being
exhausted in the room or the central
ventilation system based on how it's
hooked up after the errors didn't have a
filter so several investigators
suggested that we could take advantage
of the sensitivity of the PCR assay to
sample areas where agent Latin particles
accumulate in higher concentrations such
as the exhaust plenum of ventilator
racks to detect pathogens the strategy
was proven useful and very sensitive to
detect firm eyes at the right level but
at the time there had been no
publication on
on the efficiency of that strategy
testing strategy for pin or nonetheless
we said you know what then were max
surviving the environments for week eggs
are found a word found in the past in
the environment of conventionally house
and infected wrong economies and
although speculators eggs do not erase
lies as easily as aphasia we said well
you know what TCR might be sensitive
enough to detect only a few eggs was
just residual genetic material in the
environment in those panels so we
decided to take a leap of fate and be a
bit of an be explorers and we asked our
question John and I said can PCR on rack
exhaust plenums be a reliable and
sensitive method to assess the presence
of the norm DNA or infection at the
right level and we tested all our racks
by pool PCR in all our rooms in all our
facilities and that's when we add our
big surprise so let's go look at this
table in red what you have are the South
44 and South 50 those are the two
confirmed positive rooms you have the
pcrf eco PCR that was positive the fecal
float that were positive and as expected
not surprisingly the exhaust plenum PCR
were positive great but then we should
not you know all our sandals and all the
other rooms were negative the floats
were all negative the tapes were all
negative in all the other rooms and yet
big surprise all our plenum PCR were
positive the vast majority of our racks
in all our facilities were positive all
except in the rooms in the autoclave
rooms where the teachers are with the
corncob bedding and the critical mass
our autoclaved prior to use that was
extremely extremely disturbing for us we
said oh my gosh we have a widespread
infection in all our facility but why
didn't then our samples pick it up you
know what pinworms don't necessarily
while these
as for fairly well but they made you
know we don't necessarily test our
sandals very well it's not very
sensitive in arsenal's so you know we
might not we might have missed it in our
Sentinel so normal so we were very
concerned but we had to determine what
was going on so I had three possible
explanation to explain those results
first a widespread outbreak of pain
alarm in our facility that selectively
affected not autoclaved rooms or second
thing is that what we had was not a true
pin worm infection in all the rooms but
what we had it was historical presence
of pinworm DNA in the exhaust manifold
without active infection that's possible
ah or just our third possibility was
that the false positive environmental
PCR results was you to nonspecific
amplification of DNA so we had glad to
exclude all the three we had to work on
303 three hypotheses one after the other
a widespread outbreak that selectively
affected non autoclave rooms would have
been a very surprising considering the
negative central results in our
biosecurity program nonetheless we
decided to exclude direct offices by
testing index high risk calling the
animals from representative autoclave
rooms and honored none of the clave
rooms so basically we tested the
autoclave rooms that were negative by
plenum pcr and the non autoclave rooms
that were positive by pcr and we chose
the non other clave rooms that with the
lowest crossing point value on the
planet pcr which means that they had the
strongest pcr signal we wanted to
increase our chant our chance of finding
it in mice and what we did is we tested
breathing and breeding and young calling
nice basically a five to ten we call
calling in mice and we decided to test
those groups those animals specifically
because they are the ones that have the
most pin arms in general that's the best
those are the best candidates define it
so we did on those animals in the ruin
the representative
autoclave rooms and non autoclave rooms
with a fecal floats and pool cage pcr KH
PCR is very good and very sensitive in
general at finding pinworm at the cage
level so all the fecal floats that we
did in the autoclave rooms and the not a
particular non autoclave rooms that were
positive on plenum pcr were negative all
the pool cage pcr swabs were also
negative so we have to conclude that
really exhaust plenum pcr do not
correlate well with fecal flotation or
cage PCR results from index harvest
calling animals we also said well you
know what the probability that we have
an out a selective outbreak in non
autoclave rooms is really not not very
does not hold too much the second thing
that we said well maybe we had
historical presence of pinworm DNA in
our exhaust manifold without a net any
active infection our economy animals
however several of our racks that were
positive on exhaust plan and pcr i've
been truly decon an autoclave just one
or two months prior and the autoclave
autoclaving should have denature the DNA
so that suggested that really the
contamination would have occurred after
those dates the historical contamination
would not have explained also the
discrepancy between the autoclave and
nonequilibrium they are processed the
same way and that are circulated through
the different rooms the same way we
don't dedicate rocks to autoclave rooms
and a dedicated racks to none' crave
room once they're they're clean and
autoplay we circulate them back into
into into different rooms so we just put
that I pollicis by hypothesis aside I
have to say another thing is that in our
exhaust plenum we found some booklets
and just want to touch base really
quickly I'm sorry we found some booklets
and in our plenums and we said well
could that be a source of false positive
due to cross reaction because maybe he
had a very similar genetic material well
in fact it doesn't but we tested it
anyway we tested those those those book
lies by pcr and they were negative
and second thing that excludes that
possibility is that both autoclave and
non autoclave racks in both autoclave
and non- rooms had booked light so it
probably didn't come from the book lies
so are more looking back at the data we
want to say how can we explain the
discrepancy between the autoclave an
autoclave rooms how could we explain the
widespread positive results on plannin
pcr affecting selectively nonequilibrium
well I had to come from a component the
source of the contamination had to come
from a component used inside the cage
throughout the facility that is neither
sanitized nor autoclaved in the non
advocate room so only two component met
these criteria either corncob bedding or
the nesting material so the nesting
material the crinkle mess was not our
first suspect because it's a paper
product it has doesn't have any
nutritional value and it's an unlikely
to draw infected vermin nonetheless we
excluded I practices like just testing
by environmental pcr all the the
packaging material for the crinkle mess
that we had in our facility the room
where it was stored and on that and the
room were the room were it was
distributed distributed from all the
results were negative although it
doesn't prove anything it the
probability that what it came from the
crinkle mess was fairly low corncob at
that time was our most probable source
we said you know it's an organic
material maybe it was contaminated and
we didn't know a lot about pork oh well
we know what we knew based on what we
had read but that's about it so we
swapped the automatic bedding dispensing
unit for our corn cob all our corn cob
is dispensed into cages by a centralized
automatic bedding dispensing a unit and
so we said that's the best place to test
our cork up right so we tested that that
for pin work piece for four pin worm by
pcr and to our great surprise it was
positive and I said oh my gosh our
automatic either the corncob is is
is is is infected or the bedding
dispensing unit as vermin in it or is
infected so we emptied the reservoir and
inspected for best but we found none we
also did swabs everywhere in our in our
storage area it was all negative we also
did swaps of our pumpkin our quarter cup
distributor in their storage room of
their delivery trucks all the results
were negative so started to say well
maybe the contamination occurred earlier
between the manufacturing plant and the
distributor and we said that would be
logical basically you have contamination
of the corn cob somehow after the
production and it came into your
facility and that would explain why it
spread throughout the facility because
it's distributed in and through our
centralized betting system unit but that
didn't explain the discrepancy between
the exhaust plenums the Sentinels and
the calling the animals accepting a tomb
where we did confirm the positive pin
worm the pinworms none of the exhaust
poonam PCR results were confirming
sandals or calling the animal so we
started to doubt the specificity of the
PCR assay that new huge and for our plan
on pcr so two ties that we said you know
what we're going to take the same the
plenum swabs from the two confirmed
positive rooms from autoplay through non
autoclave rooms that were positive x
divided by pcr and by autoclave rooms
that were negative and we submitted
those samples 22 laps saying maybe they
have two different parameters two
different assays and if that if one was
not specific maybe the second one is
specific and then you're going to have a
negative results so the samples were
submitted to the original reference lab
into a second reference and big surprise
as expected well the first reference lab
in all knowledge on a non autoclaved
room
were positive again in the planet PCR
were positive when tested by the first
time in non other cave rooms and
negative in autoclave rooms that
confirms exactly the results that we had
before but when we got the results from
the second reference lab what we had was
that all the results were negative in
non of the autoclave and autoclave rooms
very interestingly is that in none other
clean rooms would confirm PCR even in
those rooms where we did confirm the
norms the plenum were negative so our
conclusion was very simple that the
primer used by the original reference
lab was not specific and just amplified
another nematode and the second thing
that is as important is that the PCR
exhaust plant plenum is not really
efficient inspected penguin in naturally
infected Mouse colony yes indeed sad 44
self if T in red of the in the table
were confirmed positive in the animals
and yet the plenums were negative so to
test the specificity of the primers from
the first reference lab what we did is
we sequence the amplicons that were
amplified by that pcr reaction from the
exhaust plenum samples so we sequence
the amplicons and then we blasted that
sequence on gene bank which is a genome
database and what we found is a hundred
percent match for three nematodes of the
relative family completely different
from pinworms suggesting that the primer
nonspecifically amplified DNA from
enough from other nematodes we then
compare the obtained amplicon relative
sequence with the known sequence of a
specular spicule errors and found a
ninety-one percent sequence identity
with the specularity 18s ribosomal RNA
gene and a hundred percent match in the
region of the primer so obviously with
those results we concluded that the
specular is positive results on our
exhaust plenum by our first reference
lab in the amount in an honor in the non
non autoclave
was a false positive you turn the non
specificity of our primers so I just
want to touch base about a touch base on
the metals in general the nematode filim
is a very rich is very rich in species
and it's very biological they're
biologically they are diverse you know
you know nematodes infect plants animals
and a lot of them are free-living
organisms that we find in in in soil etc
we estimate that there are between 1 and
10 million existing nematodes 1 to 10
million existing types of nematodes
species but only 25,000 are actually
described in the literature and only a
few oven sequence as far as the rabbit
in nematodes what are they they're the
richest group of nematodes they contain
they have about a thousands of members
many which are undiscovered they are
free-living supper phages parasites
present in every terrestrial habitat but
especially in soil and sediment because
they feed on decaying matter organic
matter including plants and bacteria and
they just convert that they just
destroyed that organic matter so they
have a very important ecological
function they are extremely extremely
resistant in the environment I'm not
talking about resistance that when
you're talking about resistance of
pinworm that's one thing but those those
those those bugs those rabbited
nematodes I'm talking you're finding
them in in remote caves that under so
harsh condition of pH temperature etc
and they still are resistant and that's
very important because you have now a
rattata nematode that process that is
ubiquitous in nature and that we found
in organic product name namely corncob
so what we said it was probably a post
production contamination of the corncob
bedding with that neematoad or just
genetic material that remain that remain
in there and that caused the false
bottles of positive results in
our planet is here that would make sense
it would make sense because it was a
widespread outbreak well widespread
dissemination of that neematoad in all
our non autoclave rooms and it probably
came from from the corn girl but I just
want to touch base on corn cob bedding
because I think it's important to
understand I hear a lot of things and
I'm the first one to two to sometimes
draw conclusions too fast I've heard a
lot of things about well corn cob
bedding can be infected with whit whit
whit whit mouse Katherine's well we've
never had confirmed infection of our
animals with mouse pathogens from the
corn cob and when you look when you hear
all those things you better go back to
the to the source and and try to
understand how really this is how really
the corn cob is done to realize that
it's almost impossible that in
contamination of the corn Earl before
production could pass through the
process and then be distributed to your
facility it's almost impossible i went i
took my i took an airplane ticket and I
went to the Midwest and I decided to go
to a corn cob betting a corn cob
manufacturing plant to try to understand
if that was possible so the corn cob is
made from the central core of night of
the maize plant not not not not not the
not the outside just this really the
core and it's passed through different
amer and roller mills to produce
fractions and then it's heated dry to
over 200 Fahrenheit sand that's really
high and then the sizes the the
fractions are sized and separated by
sifting and their dust aspirated
basically corncob bedding is produced
under extremely harsh condition and I
don't see anything that could
contaminate the corn before production
and that could survive that that process
I don't believe it and the second thing
is that the corn cob that I planned that
I saw a chewy programs everything was
done under strict quality control it was
done
under great conditions everything was
control now that something might have
happened and that the corncob in our
case got contaminated with soil or
something like that after production in
between the transfer after production
and drink transfer or whatsoever that's
possible and that's probably what is
what happened because the nematodes that
we found are ubiquitous in the nature
but that something infectious might have
passed through that process is almost
impossible so what are we learned from
this well we first we need to remain
critical when whenever we use a
diagnostic methodology don't take forgot
results for granted ask question usually
a common sense than your intuition
before implementing very costly a costly
and disturbing containment and
eradication plan choose a diagnostic lab
and I think that's essential that will
work with you and go the extra mile to
answer your question all that what
you've seen there we did in
collaboration with our reference lab in
this case we have developed an amazing
relationship with our reference lab that
their primers were not specific did not
matter why well simply for a simple
first very simple reason we use an assay
that day valid data to test biological
samples in the mouse and we experimented
we played the apprentice sorceress to
test environmental samples this was
purely an off-label application of their
PC RSS a bear test was never validated
for environmental samples and the
primers could not have been validated to
account for the thousands if not
millions of nematodes in the environment
that could have crossed reacted however
think very closely would your reference
lab of worked as hard and close as ours
to get to the bottom of all this austin
and that's why we never consider
changing they understand that diagnostic
testing is not an exact science and
that's what we value in a diagnostic
test in a reference lab like any other
diagnostic test pc are subject to false
positive and false negative any results
must be interpreted cautiously with an
over
understanding on the methodology and all
the interest and all the intrinsic
controls and all the variables that may
affect the results many aspects of the
methodology should be considered
including but not limited to the primer
design and the specificity of the
primers any potential source of
contamination that of the sample that
could have cured during manipulation at
your own facility but also anywhere
across during the transport and at the
diagnostic lab you also should
understand what type of PCR assay do
they do they do a simple pcr a
quantitative PCR a multiplex qpcr or a
nested pcr which is meant to reduce the
non specificity guiding by using two
sets of primers you know you need to all
just understand all of this before you
you you you finalize your analysis and
say well that's a true positive and
that's all your short list of things you
need to understand the second thing just
to give you an idea if you did a search
on the validation of diagnostic PCR
assays it's wrong sorry the validation
of PCR assays in general in human and
veterinary medicine medicine is very
challenging if I just did that little
exercise I did I looked at I did that
pubmed or MEDLINE search and look at all
the publications that were done to
validate a diagnostic pcr assay for TB
and humans TB is very common you'll find
about 70 to 80 scientific articles in
peer-reviewed journal just for the
validation of that assay under different
condition with different population in
different countries etc on a different
amount different server if you did the
same search on the validation of a
diagnostic pcr assay for mpv mouse Barba
virus in mice you'd found about two or
three articles that's about it so an
amazing amount of the work is done to
validate those pcr assay but you should
not think that they are bulletproof and
that especially in our small field
everything is done and redone by
multiple teams and that that they are
completely bulletproof like they might
do it in human medicine and even in
human medicine where they have so much
resources well some of their pcr assay
do fail not to say that we don't do
enough
work or that the validation process is
less stringent in our in lab animal
medicine absolutely not but again we
should not think that they are
bulletproof and that they're going to
work so how does the validation of those
primers or their PC those PCR work well
first the validation starts with the
design of the primers by a computer
modeling to optimize the PCR condition
we take into consideration primer
lengths in general the primers are about
18 to 22 base pair primer melting
temperature crimer annealing temperature
GC content content and any secondary
structure like our pain self dimers or
customer that may prevent the reaction
you know what if you have very loose a
PCR reaction you can anneal a primer to
almost any DNA sequence you got to be
you've got to design those primers very
specifically and very with that computer
model to make sure that when it went it
and nails to your sequence aidan else
correctly and very strongly second thing
is that the primer needs to be designed
to be specific that's of course that's a
that's a given so what normally
reference lab do is they normally target
ubiquiti all sleeping jeans or ribosomal
RNA common to several species to
identify the pathogen at the genus level
then one or a few sets of primers
depending on the type of PCR are
designed to target specific elements for
our organism speciation then what we do
is the specificity of the primers are
tested and compared with all available
genome databases and I want to specify I
want to I want to emphasize that all
available for for primer design for
biological samples in a mouse it's very
simple we know you know that pinworms
you know what infects the mouse that's
only a few of a few species good but
when you're looking at the environment
we're talking about millions of
different nematodes that might cross
react and many of them that have not
been sequence yet then the individual
sensitivity is a
of the primary set is verified by using
temple dilutions of target pathogens and
the specificity is you is is evaluated
user is evaluated using DNA extracted
from large banks of pathogens of the
same family and then the individual
specificity and sensitivity of this
primer is validated by testing known
clinical samples in the presence of
positive and negative control so that's
how normally the primers art design so
validation of PCR assay is a very
stringent one that might give you the
false impression that it's bulletproof
right well don't fall under the illusion
it's almost bulletproof but don't get me
wrong it's ninety-nine point nine
percent bulletproof but it's not m and n
it can fail in our case are the PCR
assay from our first reference lab
targeted a region of the 28s robert
ribosomal RNA gene coming to see fashion
yrs of alara and asp icarus petrolera it
was validated according to the same
stringent process and but the PCR assay
was not validated to test environmental
sample and and so it's not surprised
that you know we add nonspecific results
and why is that well first because Chad
genome database are continuously
evolving and basically they are
completely they are flawed incomplete
and sometimes inaccurate most of it is
accurate but you do have some flaws in
it the many of the genome database
contain and unverified or incomplete or
inaccurate sequences and they also
contain entries from genetically
different organism under the same
species as well as and every year
there's a large number of microorganisms
that are discovered every year and there
are yet to be classified or sequence
again nematode filim is very broad you
have about 1 to 10 million nematodes in
in the in the in the environment that
could cross react when you do
environmental CR as opposed to PCR on
biological sense
so I hope that I have convinced you that
although the validation process of a PCR
assay designed to test the null specific
pathogen in a biological sample from the
animal might look straight forward it's
absolutely not true for environmental
environmental PCR there's so much more
uncertainty uncertainties involved and
so many other plots possible source of
false positive results I just want to
touch base on again and come back on
planning exhaust exhaust planum PCR what
is out there in the literature because
remember that that that statement at the
beginning in the publication we could
replace old bedding testing by exhaust
fan and pcr well let's go look at the
literature what do we have what they
found is that plan on pcr was very good
for MH viens and I to monitor those bugs
or those those viruses at the RAC level
in experimentally infected mice that's
very important because experimentally in
when you do experimental infection you
give them a huge amount of virus and
they're shedding is much higher than in
natural infection so basically you
optimize you can your your chances of
finding it the exhaust blame but doesn't
represent what happens in real life the
only one publication that I've seen that
seems to show that exhaust plenum can be
useful to assess calling health status
was for fur mites that was in the
natural infection and also I saw someone
on certain bacteria like kareena betcha
but the results from exhaust plenum to
monitor colonies infected for mpv relic
0 vector that's much more variable and
as we have shown in our case to monitor
a colony that is positive for our
speaker etc it's not good remember our
two rooms that were confirmed positive
that were confirmed positive were
negative by the second reference lab on
Planet PCR overall what you need to
understand is that there's no systematic
study that have validated environmental
PCR from exhaust planet for different
organism in
natural infection or that have
determined the optimal sampling strategy
to monitor colonies when to sample them
where to sample them how often to sample
them there's just no data out there so
remember this that statement were found
in publication well although the
technology of planning PCR is very very
promising we are just not there yet not
to say that we're there's no need for
for it or that it cannot be used as a
complement to stall wedding sandals
absolutely not but we need much more
studies and more work to determine a
safe and efficient way to use it so what
have we learned from all this well pcr
can yield false positive results despite
all the safeguard used by labs to ensure
that the specificity of their asset
environmental pcr bears unique inherent
risk that you know we need to date it to
take into consideration always ask
question and confirm unexpected positive
resolved by a secondary method that's
essential before implementing costly and
containment and eradication strategy if
we had trusted our plan of pcr and then
ask any question believe me we would
have employed we would have treated
everybody in our facilities and I would
have caused a huge amount of money and
it would have caused a huge headache to
a lot of our investigators and ourselves
another conclusion is that there's no
systematic study that I've validated
environmental pcr from exhaust venom for
the different micro for all the
different microorganisms seen in nice
and there's no study that have
determined the optimal sampling strategy
and finally the environment pcr from
exhaust venom is not efficient in our
case it was not a fashion efficient in
detecting a spicule eres destructive
petrolera in natural infected Mouse
column so I think that's about it I'm
sorry I took a lot of time and if you
have any questions please please go
ahead I'll give you control up give full
control fast will control
Judy do you do you have the full control
thank you for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session I would
like to remind our audience how to
submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window will try to
answer as many questions as we can and
our first question is from judith
nielsen University of North Carolina do
you array d8r autoclave the betting on
most all cages oh sorry could you repeat
the question because I didn't hear it
okay the question is again for Judith
Nielsen University of North Carolina she
asks do you radiate or autoclave the
bedding on most all cages right a second
I'm going to get this the answer is no
we don't irradiate or autoclave
basically the corncob bedding is not is
mo the vast majority of our cages are
not autoclaved only five percent of our
cages are autoclaved with the bedding
and the crinkle nest and we don't
irradiate the corn cob
okay our next question I apologize if I
mispronounce your name or expressions
from CLE de Silva Funicello Formosan
hema centro de riviere pretto how do you
confirm the parasitism extension so if I
understand well how do I confirm the
parasite extension I'm not sure I
understand the question per se if you
mean that how did we confirm that it
well we had we had environmental results
that's one thing and then we needed to
confirm in the animal so it was it did
it extend in so was there a correlation
between our PCR results from the plenums
and in the animals and the answer was no
there was not so if that's the question
on how we confirm the extent that's how
we confirm that we also confirm the
extent in our facility by retesting our
sentinels and by testing a high in the
index high-risk animals in all in all
the rooms so that's how we we did it
Karen esque our next question is from my
umek's at Emory University she asks or
your facility Sentinel program SOPs
available online um no no they're not
it's it's something that we keep but you
know what those SOPs are fairly
standards we are so the soiled bedding
sandals are it's a very very it's fairly
standardized the way that we pass on its
its its its what you will see in the
literature there's a lot of good
articles I think there's a article that
was
that was published very recently on our
sole bedding sandals based on philosophy
and a loss but what we do is fairly
standard and we don't we don't put it on
our website or we don't make them
publicly available I'm sorry here you
have another question from judith
Nielsen University of North Carolina how
did you collect the samples for pool
cage PCR testing so that's a good
question basically for the pool cage pcr
at the cage level what they've shown is
that we you put a swab and there's an
SOP on the Charles River as well as
Radel for that for those techniques you
just put the swab at the junction of the
where where the corncob level is at the
in the cage and you go all around the
cage and you go around the kitchen swab
at that level at the level of the cage
that's for the environmental cage pcr
and the pool i think you cannot pull
more than 10 pages per swamp KR or
donate deviate from the university in
montreal asks at the manufacturing level
is the corn club ever tested for rodent
pathogens
r
to my knowledge at the at the
manufacturing plant the answer would be
no I don't believe that they test for
pathogen for Mouse pathogen of the
manufacturing plant now I just want to
emphasize something when you go there
and see what they do and how to do it if
she had a contamination at the plant
level because North scorn are taking
from corn fields they're brought into
and they're put on in huge mountains and
then they're processed through the
through the through the through the
plant that the production of the corn
cob is so harsh the temperature is so
high everything is the production
conditions are so high I don't see any
Mouse pathogens that could survive if
there is a contamination that is
possible it's post-production not it
wouldn't be pre-production I'm fairly
convinced and having looked at it and
then spent two days over there and look
how they do things I'm convinced that
that that's almost impossible so however
there could be a post-production
contamination but that's what any that's
what the food that's what it with any
products that that is produced it could
be anything from the trend during
transport it could be after the battle
you know bagging transport it could be
while you on pat it could be anywhere
but again job that you have a pathogen
that goes from the before the production
that infects the corn and then it passes
through the production or the the
processing of the corn cob I don't
believe that's possible can we have time
for one more question also from this
same questioner Aurora don't lady a how
do you know if the PCR is validated for
environmentally use
well that's the problem is that they
don't validate it for environmental
views they invited most of the PCR that
you have out there are validated for use
in biological samples from the animals
not for environmental use and you can
see based on what I've tried to explain
is that validating and making a
validating and environmental PCR is much
more difficult because you just don't
you're faced with so many other types of
organisms can I can cross-react now
don't get me wrong we were very unlucky
we were very unlucky because the
probability that you know the PCR are
our environmental PCR cross-react and
the primer was not specific was very low
I'm not going to say that it's a huge
risk but you cannot you cannot you
cannot say that those PCR special for
environmental PCR are bulletproof
there's no validation that will allow
that however they do give us an
interesting tool to assess environmental
samples but overall what needs to be
done is whenever you have a PCR results
you need to confirm in your animals you
cannot sit and say you have an
environmental PCR that is positive and
say we're going to take that as a
positive you need to confirm in the
animals that's your gold standard if you
have it in your animals then it's true
however if you have a positive on
environmental PCR it might just mean
that you have historical contamination
or DNA present in the planning but no
infectious particles in the animals it
could mean that you have a false
positive results it could be mean a lot
of things you don't always come back to
the animals always confirm any animals
unfortunately we are out of time I want
to thank the audience for their
interesting questions and participation
in today's event I would also like to
thank our sponsor the andersons lab
bedding products for making today's
educational webcast possible today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through
August 2015 you'll receive an email from
lab boots alerting you when this webcast
will be available for replay we invite
you to forward that announcement to your
colleagues your may have missed today's
live event see you next time goodbye